huawei des politiciens rallye les
troupes pour resserrer l'accès aux armes
à feu
lights à l'intérieur du capitole où si
l'émotion est forte les survivants
témoignent de leur détresse
mia 10 ans était dans la classe de 4e
année lors de la fusillade du val d
[Musique]
le tueur a tiré sur mon ami à côté de
moi j'ai mis de son sens sur moi et j'ai
fait la morte son père est venu à
washington pour dire aux élus d'agir
j'ai failli perdre mon bébé at il dit en
larmes
le massacre du valais a fait 21 morts
lambda ceux utilisés par le tueur ar 15
avec un chargeur à grande capacité a
littéralement pulvérisé le corps de
certains enfants
c'était excessivement difficile de les
identifier a dit ce médecin et puis dans
la salle l'émotion et la tristesse ont
cédé leur place à la colère
cette femme a perdu un enfant lors de la
fusillade survenue dans un centre
commercial a beau flow
l'amérique dit elle est profondément
violente ça fait partie de la culture
les chiffres sont d'ailleurs
impressionnant le comité du congrès
avaient ce tableau en toile de fond on
constate que les fusillades aux états
unis en 2019 dépasse largement le total
des tueries dans l'ensemble des autres
pays du g7 cette maman qui a perdu son
enfant réclame de l'action elle veut
l'interdiction des ventes d'armes
d'assaut
demande aussi que l'âge légal pour se
procurer une arme d'assaut passe de 18 à
21 ans et que les lois soient plus
sévères pour vérifier les antécédents
des acheteurs d'armes et elle n'est pas
la seule les démocrates le président
bail de nantes est pouces pour des
changements
des négociations se poursuivent il
faudra toutefois une entente avec les
républicains au sénat
martin personne ne peut rester
indifférent à ces témoignages tellement
déchirant reste que les négociations
elles sont extrêmement difficiles entre
démocrates et républicains
il ya eu un petit vent d'optimisme ce
matin mais qui s'est vite dissipée alors
qui a été déposé au congrès un projet de
loi pour interdire la vente d'armes
d'assaut aux jeunes de moins de 21 ans
vous savez qu'ici aux états unis les
jeunes de 18 ans ne peuvent pas acheter
de bière ne peuvent pas acheter de
cigarettes mais ils peuvent acheter des
armes d'assaut avec un chargeur à grande
capacité mais on s'est rendu compte
assez rapidement que le projet doit
n'irai pas très loin parce que au sénat
il manque l'appui d'une dizaine de
sénateurs républicains
alors ça n'allait nulle part la seule le
seul espoir qui reste finalement en fin
de journée c'est que les négociations
bipartisanes vont se poursuivre mais
c'est déjà ça mais c'est un débat qui
divise tellement le pays quoi ya deux
visions qui s'affrontent vraiment les
démocrates pensent que plus il y a deux
tueries plus il faut limiter l'accès aux
armes et les républicains pensent plutôt
que plus il ya de tueries plus il faut
permettre l'accès aux ans pour que les
américains puissent se protéger c'est
sûr qu'il ya des nuances de guilde ans
que je viens de vous dire mais consomme
au dos c'est ça le débat et les
américains et l'opinion publique elle
est divisée les sondages sont assez 50
50 alors quand on regarde ça on peut
dire ce soir que ça risque de prendre un
bon moment avant qu'il ya un changement
significatif
ouais s'il y en a un merci martin au
revoir